I never even really touched politics
when whatever's about policies that I
know nothing about but once it became
about speech and culture which is what
I'm an expert in right and and I
realized it was now infringing on my
actual career I'm like I got to start
figuring out who these people are and
what they're talking about because that
was having a conversation with a woman
recently about the word [ __ ] young
she was like oh that's so offensive and
I'm like why means underdeveloped and
she's like you're a [ __ ] I'm like
probably bring up that word Julia some
eugenics programs and Ivy buddies I got
in Henry Godard it means that your IQ
from 25 to 50 and she's like you're an
idiot
Am I whoa why do you bring up that word
it actually means zero to twenty five
idiots quote unquote word a lot of boat
in California until 2007 and like
[ __ ] was the PC term because those
terms were so offensive and I thought
that she'd like smile and high-five me
but when I saw in her eyes that she
didn't want to know anything yeah
Gemma's like no you're wrong I'm like
but you now no I'm not and it doesn't
change your opinion and that's why I
became a fan of your show is listening
to you debate people even if at first I
thought I agreed with something someone
else said and how he meticulously stuck
to logic points debate top you know I
was like that's how life has to be to
have a marketplace of ideas or else
we're all screwed well I'm thank you
that's very very kind of you to say but
it seems like you're doing a pretty good
job yourself
yeah we've said mentally [ __ ] in the
show and they'll be like you know the
one thing goal is bring out right as
they preach and I understand it's
collaborative a tactic to preempt their
argument to know what they're going to
say now we do that for example but we do
it in the way we go this is their
policies is what they believe this is
the statistic they'll bring out you're
more likely to be shot if there's a gun
in your household this is why that's
false but they just preempt it and say
it's wrong or it's racist and it's the
same thing they do with you know
mentally [ __ ] as one which is well
you know what you or if you if you
haven't if you say well listen actually
I happen to work with black people I
also you're talking out your black
friend listen actually a perfectly valid
defense if you're accusing me of being a
racist
saying
I clearly don't hate black people
because were my closest friend you're
black - well same when we use the word
mentally [ __ ] my wife and I
volunteered four years at a church which
they hate when they do a program called
friendship club and it's with special
needs people now what were their we're
not going to do recorder to join me you
know I'm not going to do that but every
now and then you'll describe somewhat
low this person is mentally [ __ ] and
it's not meant to be hateful now and if
you call something else [ __ ] it's
not meant to be hateful but then let's
say oh you're trying to trot out you're
specially abled friend does it it's kind
of a valid defense they clearly don't
hate mentally [ __ ] people if I want
with them the very descriptive word in
knowing you know this it's actually a
music term to mean slow to arrive and I
think an actual meaning but in music and
the employer talking about retarding the
end of a [ __ ] note yeah that's why
look I'm not throwing the word around
trying to like show people how much
smarter hand in them I'm not trying to
bait people who want it to valid use
it's like the word niggard yes it's
Shakespeare like these words exist and
when people make people a polished act
is from like words sounding like other
words like niggardly means cheap it's
from what does that Macbeth like yeah
yeah let's be fair it doesn't come up in
everyday conversation so often usually
if you're waiting into niggardly
territory it's a bit of a baited hook
totally but my sisters I know some
people that are so nerdy and cognitive
to the point where they act like throw a
little spectrum like I'm a physicist
friend like that and if he used to turn
like that you get in trouble and in his
mind he's like but that was the precise
term apparently a friend's inner
monologue sounds like a dog he does it
was though his term I told me he pointed
out ago that Caitlyn Jenner was woman of
the year but she hasn't been a woman for
an entire year and uh and and he's now
could be the scientist amassment yeah
yeah yeah and it goes Caitlyn Jenner
times fraction of years less than what
it's not possible and I'm just crying
laughing
and what if you just sidestep the
biggest minefield in the history of
comedy you don't even realize just
choosing math he also said that if he
was katham he would commit crimes on
clear nights because he goes the best
symbol must reflect off the surface and
without clouds you wouldn't be able to
alert that man
so it follows the criminal I would
commit crimes when there were no clouds
that's the guy who uses niggardly it
doesn't evoke a that's correct
we'll give will give him his niggardly
past I you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button it's a circular
button now that says subscribe if not
head on over the Young Turks that's
probably more your speed although
they're coming over here [ __ ] we know
you're here watching I can smell you
from here there's also a recommended
video box playing right up there you can
join the Mugler but a lot of credit comm
slash mug Club for daily content so
we're not dependent here on YouTube
shank go/no-go you don't need to stay
here this isn't good for it's bad for
your soul